salut c'est hugo et j'espère que vous
allez bien nouvel épisode de cette série
sur les programmes des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de marine le
pen on va se pencher sur son programme
en dix mesures majeures liées au passage
pour prolonger là dessus mais ça vous
intéresse sur cette chaîne youtube vous
pouvez retrouver dès maintenant mon
interview face cachée de marine le pen à
l'occasion de la présidentielle ainsi
que les décryptages des programmes ainsi
que les interviews de tous les autres
candidats dont les prochains jours
pensez donc à vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube je ne sais pas encore le
cas et enfin sur notre compte instagram
hugo décrypte vous allez pouvoir
découvrir dans les prochains jours des
comparaisons des positions des candidats
à l'élection présidentielle sur
plusieurs grandes thématiques
on commence avec une petite présentation
marine le pen à 53 ans elle est la fille
de jean-marie le pen co fondateur du
front national un parti classé à
l'extrême droite auquel marine le pen a
adhéré dès ses 18 ans et qui a été
renommé en 2018 le rassemblement
national sachant que marine le pen
refuse toujours cette appellation
d'extrême droite marine le pen a fait
des études de droit à paris elle devient
avocate au début des années 90 en
politique par ailleurs elle a été élue
pour la première fois en 1998 en tant
que conseillère régionale du nord pas de
calais l'a été il eut notamment députée
européenne en 2014 et député du
pas-de-calais en 2017 c'est la troisième
candidature de marine le pen pour cette
élection présidentielle en 2012 elle
s'était classée à la troisième place
avec 17 6% des voix et en 2017 elle
s'était qualifié au second tour avec
21,3 pour cent des voix où elle a
ensuite étaient battus par emmanuel
macron en recueillant 33 9% des voix
alors si elle est élue présidente marine
le pen affirme que sa première mesure
sera d'engager un référendum sur
l'immigration car elle veut en fait
faire du contrôle de l'immigration une
priorité pour la france alors avec ce
référendum elle veut faire adopter une
loi qu'elle intitulerait citoyenneté
identité immigration et qui vise à
réduire très fortement l'immigration en
france mais aussi réduire les droits des
étrangers elle comporte en fait beaucoup
de mesures cette loi et donc je vais en
détailler certaines alors si les
français approuvent et votent cette loi
par référendum les étrangers qui n'ont
pas travaillé pendant un an seront
expulsés pareil pour les étrangers qui
ont été condamnés par la justice
ensuite le droit du sol qui permet donc
aujourd'hui d'acquérir la nationalité
française si on est sur le territoire
français etc ont rempli certains
critères seraient également supprimés
autre changement les allocations
familiales seraient réservées aux
français le revenu de solidarité active
donc ce revenu pour les personnes les
plus démunies serait interdite aux
étrangers qui n'ont pas travaillé plus
de cinq ans en france et l'aide médicale
d'état et me ce qui est donc une aide
médicale pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière seraient également supprimés
par ailleurs autre élément majeur marine
le pen souhaite aussi rendre
prioritaires les français par rapport
aux étrangers notamment dans le cadre
d'une offre d'emploi ou encore d'un
logement deuxième mesure marine le pen
souhaite je cite faire de la sécurité
partout et pour tous la priorité de son
quinquennat pour ça elle veut notamment
rétablir ce que l'on appelle les peines
plancher alors les peines planchers être
assez compliqué de l'expliquer comme ça
en d'obo mais je vais essayer en gros ça
avait été mise en place en 2007 par
nicolas sarkozy en cas de récidive donc
de nouveaux crimes par exemple d'un
individu et ça avait pour objectif en
fait d'imposer une peine minimale l'idée
étant donc que tous criminels ou
délinquants dans cette situation de
récidive est bien une sanction au moins
à ce niveau de peines plancher déjà
défini sa en l'occurrence avaient été
supprimés en 2014 sous françois hollande
pour mettre en avant davantage que l'on
appelle l'individualisation des peines
et donc marine le pen souhaite rétablir
ces peines plancher autre élément en
matière de justice marine le pen
souhaite également supprimer toute
possibilité de réduction et
d'aménagement de peine en particulier
pour les violences contre les personnes
et établir par ailleurs la possibilité
d'une peine de prison à perpétuité
réelle donc une réelle peine de prison à
vie et ce sans aucun aménagement pour
certains crimes troisième mesure marine
le pen veut faire changer le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
alors contrairement à ses deux
précédentes campagnes présidentielles
désormais elle ne souhaite plus que la
france quitte l'union européenne elle ne
souhaite plus non plus que la france
quitte l'euro et elle ne veut pas non
plus organiser de référendum sur ces
sujets en fait désormais elle est
persuadée de pouvoir changer l'union
européenne de l'intérieur disons en
restant également donc dans la zone euro
est en fait en s'alliant avec d'autres
gouvernements européens qui veulent
changer l'union européenne comme viktor
orban par exemple un allié de marine le
pen en hongrie marine le pen dit
d'ailleurs souvent qu'elle souhaite que
sa première visite officielle soit à
bruxelles justement pour aller négocier
les traités européens qui sont en place
aujourd'hui et pour que l'union
européenne ait moins de pouvoir et que
le droit français redevienne supérieur
au droit européen
là je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais ce serait un défi absolument majeur
pour le permettre je vous mets des liens
en description si jamais ça vous
intéresse quatrième mesure marine le pen
souhaite supprimer les impôts sur le
revenu pour tous les moins de 30 ans en
france peu importe leur revenu ça
concernerait donc des personnes modestes
comme des personnes ayant des revenus
très importants comme par exemple
killian mba p l'objectif de cette mesure
selon elle c'est d'encourager les jeunes
à rester en france et de ne pas aller à
l'étranger mais cette mesure pourrait
être compliqué à mettre en place puisque
la constitution donc la loi suprême du
pays garantit aujourd'hui que deux
personnes en situation égale et aux
revenus égaux doivent payer le même
impôt au nom de l'égalité devant l'impôt
autres mesures majeures pour les jeunes
en matière d'imposition elle souhaite
également supprimer l'impôt sur les
sociétés des entrepreneurs de moins de
30 ans donc l'impôt que doivent payer
ces entreprises qui sont gérés par des
personnes de moins de 30 ans et ce
pendant les cinq premières années de
leur entreprise là aussi dans l'objectif
est bien d'encourager à entreprendre
directement en france et ne pas partir
par exemple aux etats-unis 5 il mesure
désormais une mesure plutôt originale
pour les plus jeunes c'est l'été lui
marine le pen rendra possible un prêt de
l'état à taux zéro sur dix ans donc sans
avoir à payer des intérêts mais les
conditions de ce prêt sont assez
particuliers vous allez voir
en gros les couples qui souhaitent
acheter un logement et dont la moyenne
d'âge est inférieure à 30 ans et dont au
moins un des deux est français et bien
pour se faire prêter jusqu'à 100000
euros par l'état pour compléter par
exemple un prêt immobilier qui a été
pris avec la bande or la particularité
de ce prêt à taux zéro c'est que il ne
sera plus nécessaire de rembourser ce
prêt dès lors que ce couple met au monde
son troisième enfant donc le montant qui
restera rembourser après ce troisième
enfant deviendra un don et non plus du
coup un montant à rembourser l'objectif
avec tout ça vous l'aurez peut-être
compris c'est donc de faciliter l'accès
à la propriété
mais surtout et bien d'encourager les
naissances 6e mesures pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat marine le pen propose
d'encourager les entreprises à augmenter
les salaires les plus faibles en ne
mettant pas de cotisations patronales
donc pas de cotisation que l'entreprise
doit payer aujourd'hui sur toute
augmentation de salaire allant jusqu'à
10% ça pourrait donc s'appliquer à tous
les salaires allant jusqu'à trois fois
le salaire minimum l'objectif c'est donc
d'encourager les entreprises à augmenter
les salaires puisque deux fait ça leur
coûterait moins cher sans ces
cotisations la septème mesure qui vise à
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français marine le pen veut baisser la
tva donc la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée
qui est présente aujourd'hui sur les
carburants le gaz et le fioul en faisant
passer cette tva de 20% à 5 5% qui en
fait le taux appliqué aujourd'hui sur
les produits de première nécessité et
pour voir l'impact de cette mesure si on
prend le prix d'un litre de gazole qui
est en février 2020 autour d'un euro ce
sont 10 le litre eh bien il baisserait
de plus de 20 centimes pour s'établir
aux alentours d'1 euro 48 c'est une
mesure qui est portée aussi par des
partis à gauche jean luc mélenchon
fabien roussel ou encore anne hidalgo y
sont favorables et qui représenterait un
manque à gagner pour l'état d'environ 8
milliards d'euros lui tienne mesures
concernant l'environnement et bien
marine le pen et pro nucléaires dont
qu'elle veut si elle est élue lancer la
construction de six réacteurs nouvelle
génération de type e p r un peu comme ce
qu'a annoncé mille macron il y a
quelques jours marine le pen veut
également réouvrir la centrale nucléaire
la plus vive en france la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim qui a été fermé
en juin 2021 enfin autre élément sur
l'environnement marine le pen souhaitent
démanteler et retirer toutes les
éoliennes en france car selon elles
elles polluent visuellement le paysage
mais surtout selon elles elles ne sont
pas une source d'énergie suffisamment
fiable par exemple en comparaison avec
le nucléaire la 9e mesure désormais
concerne la retraite comme jean luc
mélenchon marine le pen avait annoncé au
départ vouloir baisser l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 60 ans à taux plein vous
allez revenu en fait sur cette
proposition puisque désormais elle
propose que l'âge minimal de départ à la
retraite soit de 62 ans est donc reste à
62 ans mais elle souhaite par contre que
les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler avant leurs 20 ans puissent
partir plus tôt l'objectif selon elle
c'est de compenser la pénibilité de
certains emplois car selon elle je cite
travailler plus tôt c'est travailler
plus dur dernière mesure marine le pen
veut augmenter le budget du ministère de
la défense de plus de 30% d'ici à 2027
pourquoi ce budget atteignant fait 55
milliards d'euros l'objectif c'est que
la france puisse être davantage
indépendante sur le plan militaire et ça
rejoint cette deuxième mesure majeure
qui est le fait de sortir de l'otan
l'otan étant donc que cette organisation
militaire dont la france fait partie qui
est menée par les états unis une
organisation dont on entend beaucoup
parler en ce moment dans le cadre du
conflit en ukraine allez pour terminer
comme pour chacun des candidats on va
évoquer quelques mesures supplémentaires
sachant qu évidemment il y aura des
informations en descriptions marine le
pen propose de rendre gratuits les
trains pour les jeunes de moins de 25
ans mais uniquement aux heures creuses
donc c'est à dire les horaires qui
s'affiche actuellement à l'écran elle va
aussi créer cent mille nouveaux
logements sociaux elle propose de
revaloriser l'allocation adulte
handicapé elle souhaite aussi instaurer
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
permettrait donc de pouvoir organiser un
référendum sur un sujet qui a recueilli
un certain nombre de signatures elle
souhaite organiser un référendum sur
l'écologie aussi avec quinze questions
notamment en faveur du localisme donc le
fait de privilégier les produits locaux
et de limiter l'importation de produits
étrangers autres mesures elle souhaite
renationaliser les autoroutes pour
qu'elle soit gérée par l'état et
souhaite créer un ministère d'état de là
mr et de l'outre-mer ainsi qu'un
ministère dédié spécifiquement à la
lutte contre les fraudes et enfin si
elle est élue marine le pen supprimerait
immédiatement le pass vaccinale voit
donc pour ce qui est du programme de
marine le pen sachant que j'ai me voulez
plus d'information je le disais j'ai
interviewé marine le pen il y a quelques
jours comme les autres candidats du coup
cette interview est déjà disponible sur
cette chaîne youtube ça permet de
rentrer davantage en profondeur sur les
éléments de débat majeur sur certains de
ces sujets qu'on a pu évoquer
aujourd'hui du coup nous n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner sûr mais ce n'est pas
encore le cas rendez vous aussi je le
disais sur instagram pour plus de
contenu prenez soin de vous présent nos
proches et on se dit ah très vite